et c'est la fin des questions au
gouvernement on refait les casques sur
LCP on refait les questions au
Gouvernement très heureuse de vous
retrouver ici en direct de la salle des
pas perdus à quelques mètres de
l'hémicycle ou vient de s'achever cette
séance de questions d'actualité alors on
va revenir sur les temps forts de cette
séance avec Stéphanie Despierre et Elsa
mandingava qui se trouve celle des
quatre colonnes et puis nous
retrouverons également Marco pommier qui
est lui au cours d'honneur il aura des
ministres à la sortie de l'hémicycle et
puis Marion Becker est-elle dans la
manifestation parisienne
on va retrouver Stéphanie des pierres
justement pour le compte-rendu de cette
séance alors Stéphanie vous vous retenez
un échange entre Charles zintenstool le
député Renaissance et Olivier Véran
porte-parole du gouvernement c'est au
sujet et bien des liens avérés dans un
rapport de la commission d'enquête sur
le RN et Vladimir Poutine oui Brigitte
la température est brusquement montée
d'un cran dans l'hémicycle quand Charles
Simpson a pris la parole le député
Renaissance a voulu reparler de la
commission d'enquête sur les ingérences
étrangères dans ce dans son rapport
cette commission
a dénoncé le rassemblement national
comme une courroie de transmission de la
Russie en France le rapport a été adopté
jeudi l'ironie de cette histoire c'est
que cette commission avait été lancée
par le rassemblement national justement
pour laver son honneur l'objectif est
rater le rassemblement national et
furieux et c'est la guerre entre les
Troupes de Marine Le Pen et Renaissance
et on l'a vu tout à l'heure car les
députés du rassemblement national ont
tenté de perturber la question du député
Renaissance il y avait des cris des
brouhaha des hués certains tu n'as pas
lu le rapport Marine Le Pen la même
montré du doigt le député essence est
alors senti menacé à leur côté
gouvernement c'est Olivier Véran qui a
répondu à la question du député et
pendant réponse dans laquelle il a
qualifié Marine Le Pen carrément de
Pantin de Poutine sous les yeux
évidemment des bancs du rassemblement
national et puis dernier épisode de ces
de ce face à face à couteau tirer entre
Renaissance et le rassemblement national
et bien c'est quand Frédéric Falcon
député de Marine Le Pen a lancé avant sa
question député Renaissance vous êtes la
honte de l'Assemblée nationale
merci Stéphanie despier et puis vous le
savez lundi la première ministre a fait
des annonces sur le logement service
après-vente cet après-midi du ministre
Olivier quincolon retrouve au micro de
Marco pommier ministre délégué donc
chargé de la ville et du logement
oui Brigitte Olivier Klein beaucoup de
questions cet après-midi dans
l'hémicycle sur les annonces de la
première ministre pour tenter d'enrayer
la crise du logement mais le compte n'y
est pas pour les acteurs du secteur il
n'y a plus de politique du logement
distillent vous leur répondez quoi
aujourd'hui mais je leur réponds que
c'est tout le contraire d'abord il y a
eu une politique du logement dans le
quinquennat précédent le plan logement
d'abord 440 000 personnes qui ont quitté
la rue le lancement de ma prime rénov le
doublement du budget de l'Agence
nationale de la rénovation urbaine qui
est passée de 5 à 12 milliards donc
c'est même plus qu'un doublement et puis
les annonces qui ont été faites hier
c'est d'abord la suite d'un magnifique
chantier celui du Conseil national de la
refondation qui a été voulu par le
Président de la République et la
première ministre avec des annonces
fortes à la fois structurelles et puis
des annonces pour répondre à la crise
l'acquisition de 50 000 logements entre
la Caisse des Dépôts habitat et Action
Logement le maintien du prêt à taux zéro
alors qu'il devait s'arrêter le maintien
du prêt à taux zéro et sa prolongation
jusqu'en 2027 que jusqu'à présent il
était renouvelé chaque année avec un
doute donc on donne de la visibilité aux
acteurs du logement une politique de
rénovation thermique qui est renforcée
simplifié mieux accompagner donc c'est
tout ça qui a été annoncé par la
première ministre et qui sont le fruit
de réflexion et puis surtout comme la
première ministre l'a dit comme je l'ai
dit la restitution d'hier et tout sauf
un point final le Conseil national de la
refondation a posé des bases à
travailler à créer ce que je souhaitais
c'est à dire une union sacrée et
réellement tous les acteurs l'ont dit
cette émulation cette capacité à
travailler ensemble beaucoup des acteurs
du logement qui étaient présents qui
sont de entre guillemets de vieux
acteurs du logement on dit que c'était
peut-être une des premières fois qu'ils
avaient vu une telle volonté alors oui
il y a des attentes elles sont légitimes
mais je peux vous assurer que le
gouvernement est au rendez-vous et qu'on
continuera à travailler notamment avec
la signature du pacte de confiance avec
le monde HLM qui est l'étape d'après et
on laisse cette étape à venir merci
beaucoup Olivier Klein pour vos réponses
merci beaucoup
merci Marco pommier l'actualité c'est
aussi la réforme des retraites et la
manifestation contre cette réforme 250
rassemblements un petit peu partout en
France aujourd'hui on va retrouver
Marion Becker qui est donc dans la
manifestation parisienne et c'est la 14e
journée de mobilisation Marion
[Musique]
oui effectivement vous l'avez dit
Brigitte 14e journée de mobilisation une
mobilisation en net baisse aujourd'hui
selon les chiffres officiels mais les
syndicats le reconnaissent aussi
également le plus faible niveau 2 de
participation il n'y a pas eu de sursaut
les chiffres de la manifestation
parisienne ne sont pas encore connues
mais à titre d'exemple ce matin à
Marseille ils étaient 50000 selon ses
organisateurs 4000 selon la police alors
qu'ils étaient 130 000 au 1er mai et
même dans les bastions de la
mobilisation à l'Ouest notamment à
Nantes ils étaient entre 8000 et 20000
ou à Rennes entre 5 et 10000 Laurent
Berger l'a dit lui-même ce matin la
mobilisation le match est en train de se
terminer la mobilisation doit prendre de
nouvelles formes Sophie Binet elle
appelle à une interse syndicale unie
après cinq mois de mobilisation c'est un
petit peu du fatalisme un baroud donneur
auquel on assiste aujourd'hui en tout
cas à Paris merci Marion Becker et la
CGT annonce 300 000 manifestants à Paris
alors qu'on s'attendait entre 50 et 70
000 ce ne sont que les chiffres de la
CGT en tout cas pour le moment Caroline
Fiat merci d'être avec nous pour cette
émission vous êtes député la France
insoumise de Meurthe-et-Moselle
vice-présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
à vos côtés Perrine Goulet bonjour merci
d'être là député démocrate modem et
indépendante de la Nièvre Caroline Fiat
je reviens vers vous effectivement une
mobilisation qui est en forte baisse
aujourd'hui est-ce que le match est en
train de se terminer comme le dit
Laurent Berger est-ce que vous acceptez
finalement que que cette manifestation
cette mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites prennent fin non le match ne
s'arrête pas effectivement il y a moins
de monde dans la rue aujourd'hui faut
pas oublier que ça fait 6 mois que la
mobilisation a lieu une journée de
mobilisation c'est une journée sans
salaire on est dans une période
d'inflation aussi que une journée sans
salaire ça commence à être difficile
pour les salariés ce n'est pas parce que
ils ne sont pas dans la rue qui ne sont
pas motivés et opposés à cette réforme
donc effectivement au moins non dans la
rue mais pour autant quand vous regardez
les sondages par rapport à cette réforme
des Français ils sont toujours opposés
alors vous reconnaissez effectivement
que l'opposition reste forte même si
elle est pas dans la rue aujourd'hui
l'opinion publique est contre vous sur
cette réforme des retraites alors moi je
j'ai pas tout à fait la lecture sur la
partie il y a moins de manifestants
parce que la grève coûte cher moi je
durant cette période entre les
manifestations on a aussi continué à
expliquer aux Français tous les
avantages de cette réforme des retraites
pour les femmes pour les petites
retraites etc et je pense que ça
commence
qui plus est on voit bien il y a moins
de il y a moins aussi dans de Gênes dans
les à la RATP à la SNCF dans les
l'entreprise qui d'habitude eux n'ont
pas ce problème de entre autres de
pouvoir d'achat donc on voit bien pour
moi que effectivement cette histoire de
pouvoir d'achat c'est pour casser cacher
en tout cas la désillusion je pense de
tous les syndicats sur le fait qu'il y a
personne quasiment dans la rue et on
voit bien la côte de confiance
d'Emmanuel Macron remonte alors que on
vient de passer les décrets donc moi je
pense qu'il y a un sentiment aussi
d'explication de d'acceptabilité qui est
en train de monter dans le pays sur
cette réforme de décret qui en fait ont
été publiés dimanche juste avant cette
manifestation et la proposition de loi
du groupe liote qui sera débattue jeudi
pour abroger la réforme vous l'avez vécu
comme une provocation Caroline Fiat oui
parce que enfin il y a un moment donné
enfin je me dis quand vous avez les
Français qui vous disent non surtout pas
que vous avez le texte qui doit arriver
jeudi on attend de voir comment ça va se
passer vous vous dites face sincèrement
faut arrêter de marcher sur la
démocratie faut arrêter de nous
bâillonner mais juste en tant que les
cheminots ne sont pas marqués par
l'inflation n'ont pas de problème de
frigo vide je leur laisse apprécier les
propos alors cette réforme des retraites
on en parle parce qu'il y a cette
manifestation et parce qu'il y a en
principe un débat avec une proposition
de loi du groupe liotte qui sera débattu
jeudi dans l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
nationale le président du Groupe liotte
Bertrand pencher interrogé tout à
l'heure lors des questions au
Gouvernement la première ministre je
vous propose d'écouter la réponse qui
lui a été faite
votre proposition de loi est
inconstitutionnelle elle aggraverait
lourdement les charges publiques
réduiraient les recettes elles ne
connais frontalement l'article 40 de
notre Constitution et avec vos alliés
insoumis vous persévérez dans une
deuxième atteinte à notre Constitution
le contrôle de la recevabilité a été
dévoyé à des fins uniquement partisanes
et aujourd'hui dans une nouvelle
atteinte au principe même de notre
démocratie vous prétendez
ignorer un vote clair et net en
commission des affaires sociales qui a
abrogé le premier article de votre
proposition de loi alors monsieur le
Président penchère la démagogie permet
de faire les gros titres mais elle
conduit aux déceptions au colère et au
rejet de la politique comme de nos
institutions
et nous accordons un droit de réponse à
Bertrand pencher dans le président du
groupe lyaute qui se trouve à vos côtés
Elsa mon Agava elle n'a pas été tondre
la première ministre elle vous a accusé
de multiplier les attentes contre la
Constitution et d'être des démagogues
que lui répondez-vous que je lui posais
la question
qui était la suivante quand elle
est-elle faire en sorte d'apaiser notre
pays et elle me répond en répondant de
l'huile sur le feu je pense qu'elle se
rend pas du tout compte de la situation
de notre pays je pense vraiment qu'elle
se rend pas compte de la grave crise
politique et institutionnelle qu'elle
est en train de déclencher pour la
première fois depuis la Cinquième
République vous m'entendez bien on va
interdire à des parlementaires par le
biais de leur groupe politique ce qui
est toujours la tradition de déposer une
proposition de loi on va bâillonner le
Parlement et on va on va nous interdire
de voter
très rapidement comment ça va se passer
d'après vous jeudi matin un texte vidé
de sa substance est-ce que vous allez
quand même siéger dans l'hémicycle j'en
sais rien il faut déjà poser la question
à la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
celle qui va voir le dernier mot est-ce
qu'elle va voir le courage de résister à
toutes ces pressions est-ce qu'elle va
apparaître comme une présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale qui défend la
démocratie la séparation des pouvoirs où
est-ce qu'elle va être une présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale qui avoir l'image
d'être celle qui aura réellement
affaibli durablement nos institutions et
donner l'image d'une démocratie qui part
dans n'importe quel sens
vous maintenez malgré tout le texte
peut-être pour avoir une deux heures
trois heures de tribune politique aussi
c'est le cas d'abord on prendra
l'opinion publique à témoin on
expliquant qui est responsable de cette
grave crise et en demandant aux
Françaises et Français maintenant se
mobiliser à notre côté à nos côtés c'est
plus possible que ça dure comme ça puis
ensuite bon évidemment on prendra nos
responsabilités si c'est uniquement pour
présenter l'article 2 notre proposition
de loi c'est-à-dire une conférence
sociale alors que les organisations
syndicales viennent même elles-mêmes de
dire que ça n'avait aucun sens de les
réunir puisque tout est évidé de sa
substance tout ça est ridicule merci
beaucoup Bertrand pencheur évidemment on
continue à suivre ce feuilleton autour
de votre proposition de Perrine Goulay
est-ce que vous souhaitez que la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
reprennent la main et juge et recevable
cette ce texte finalement alors moi je
vais déjà mettre Eric Coquerel devant
ses responsabilités c'est lui le
président de la commission des finances
comme pour chaque texte tous les
amendements sont évalués par la
commission des finances et par son
président pour vérifier si son conforme
à lactique le 40 non c'est déjà prononcé
avant la commission aussi d'autres donc
après moi j'appelle aussi Eric
coquerelette cohérent hier il a supprimé
8 des 16 amendement en commission des
affaires sociales sur la PPL valthou au
titre de l'article 40 avec des sommes
qui étaient bien moins engageantes que
l'amendement qui va être proposé demain
par le groupe lyaute donc moi j'engage
vraiment Eric Coquerel déjà à remplir
son rôle de président de la commission
des finances et pas de militants
politiques parce que là il a fait une
décision politique elle est pas encore
faite j'ai pas vu aucun amendement tombé
donc pour le moment les amendements
n'ont pas été vus par la clinion et
après si Éric Coquerel ne met pas en
place cet article 40 sur les amendements
qui coûtent 15 moi j'appelle à ce qu'il
n'y ait aucun amendement qu'on a déposé
qui soit aussi sanctionné par l'article
40 et qu'on puisse débattre de tout ce
que moi en tout cas j'ai aussi des
sujets à apporter ça veut dire quoi
faire de l'obstruction à ce moment-là
dans l'émission moi j'ai les amendements
clairement construit par exemple pour
repousser une des mesures qui fait que
les parents qui ont des enfants placés
avant 4 ans bien ne bénéficient pas des
trimestres moi je souhaite qu'on le
pousse à 18 ans donc c'est pas de
l'amendement c'est vraiment de
l'amélioration du texte puisqu'on n'a
pas pu le temps de le faire
l'amélioration de texte puisque au
moment des débats on était bloqués par
une obstruction systématique pour pas
arriver à l'article 7 et puis en tout
cas on a là pour moi une pleine
démagogie puisque de toute façon quoi
qu'il arrive ce texte adopté ou pas il
n'y aura jamais au bout la loi
s'appliquera au 1er septembre 2023 quoi
qu'il arrive et on est là en fait dans
deux personnes que soit monsieur pencher
ou ou son collègue qui pour une fois on
la possibilité d'exister et en profite
mais entre un qui avait fait la campagne
pour 65 ans et monsieur le rapporteur
qui avait avec Monsieur Vigier déposé
d'un pour être à 65 ans il y a quelques
années on voit bien que là on est
complètement dans la démagogie et on
fait croire à la population qu'on peut
revenir dessus mais ça ne reviendra pas
dessus parce que c'est
anticonstitutionnel et quand on parle de
respecter notre Parlement respecter
notre Parlement c'est respecter notre
Constitution et respecter notre
Constitution c'est que le président de
la commission des finances tiennent son
rôle Caroline Fiat est-ce qu'il y a pas
une forme de d'incohérence vous avez
fait de l'obstruction sur la réforme des
retraites pour ne pas arriver au débat
sur l'article 7 qui était le débat sur
l'âge et aujourd'hui vous souhaitez bien
qu'il y ait ce débat finalement dans
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée nationale
c'est-à-dire rien comprendre oui alors
vous me permettrez juste revenir sur
l'incohérence des propos là parce que
vous dites que le texte n'irait pas
jusqu'au bout donc pourquoi pourquoi ne
pas aller au vote sur ce texte qui de
toute manière de toute manière n'y
aurait pas jusqu'au bout donc pourquoi
l'assemblée ne pouvait pas le voter
ensuite vous parlez des amendements
articles 40 sauf que là on parle d'un
amendement de réécriture de texte ce qui
n'a rien à voir ce serait la première
fois sous la Cinquième République avec
un amendement de réécriture ne serait
pas repris on est là
donc ce serait la première fois sous la
5e République que un amendement de
réécriture ne serait pas repris ensuite
l'article 40 sous les sur les PPL toutes
les PPL propositions de loi la majorité
des propositions de loi sont gagées
parce que pour faire une proposition de
loi souvent il faut déposer des pensées
de l'argent exemple dernier exemple en
date la proposition de loi bien vieillir
de la majorité qu'aux signé par la
présidente Aurore berger coûté 8
milliards 13 milliards d'euros une
paille c'est à dire le même prix que
cette proposition de loi personne mais
personne n'a rien dit donc vous me dites
c'est ta géométrie variable c'est-à-dire
que là le groupe Renaissance modem
horizon personne ne s'est dit 13
milliards d'euros la France n'a pas les
moyens la preuve en est pour 13
milliards d'euros nous demande de
travailler deux ans de plus la personne
ne s'est dit on peut on prend pas cette
proposition de loi la elle est passée là
sur les retraites tout le monde de sa
fin un scandale personne n'a saisir une
Coquerel en disant bien vieillir il faut
surtout pas qu'elle passe 13 milliards
c'est pas possible moi j'allerte s'il a
on refuse cette proposition de loi il
n'y aura plus de niche parlementaire il
n'y aura plus de semaines par le
parlementaire avec des propositions
parce qu'on ne pourra plus faire de
propositions de loi parce qu'on ne
pourra plus gâcher parce que je vous le
donne en mille qu'est-ce qu'on fera les
oppositions quand on verra un texte pour
lequel on est contre on dira hop hop
c'est gâcher ça coûte 2 euros c'est
gâcher on en veut pas c'est c'est
anti-démocratique alors l'amendement
donc parler ma collègue c'est un qui
arrive jeudi pour lequel on va un
article 45 amendement de réécriture de
rétablissement est effectivement d'un
amendement supprimé en commission alors
qu'est-ce que vous répondez sur le gage
finalement
à l'encontre des droits de l'opposition
finalement s'il y a plus de niche
parlementaires la semaine dernière
d'ailleurs il a pas su me répondre il
m'a demandé de lui envoyer un courrier
pour par me répondre parce qu'en fait si
on la PPL le gage qui était sur la PPL
était mauvais puisque le gage qui donc
gage cette PPL aurait dû porter sur le
projet de loi de la sécurité sociale ce
qu'il était mais également sur le projet
de loi de finance et là il n'y avait pas
de gage sur le projet référence donc on
voit bien que même là la commission des
finances et son président n'ont pas fait
leur job parce que il aurait fallu
retoquer en disant le gars je n'ai pas
bon vous demandez une charge
supplémentaire sur le projet de finance
notamment sur tout ce qui est les
pensions civiles et militaires or ce
n'est pas gagé donc du début c'est une
fumisterie ce texte là c'est vraiment de
la politique politiciens et vraiment on
a donné un espoir en français qui n'a
pas lieu effectivement mais en un mot
est-ce qu'il y a une motion de censure
qui est en préparation si toutefois vous
allez pas au vote vous vous souhaitez
qu'il y en ait une ben moi en tout cas
j'espère que on ira au vote jeudi et on
va déjà attendre ce qui se passe jeudi
parce que sincèrement je ne vois pas la
démocratie de bâillonnée jeudi je suis
peut-être naïve mais j'attends ttends de
voir ce qui se passe jeudi en tout cas
dès jeudi et juste avant 9h à 8h55 on se
retrouvera évidemment sur LCP pour
suivre ce débat sur la proposition de
loi du groupe lui autres merci à toutes
les deux d'avoir participé à cette
émission merci à Stéphanie Despierre
Elsa mon Agava Marco pommier et Marion
Becker qui était dans la manifestation
parisienne merci à vous tous de nous
avoir suivis rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro et bien
des des questions au gouvernement
[Musique]